okay so here's what happens over the
weekend patriot
prayer shows up in portland they're
driving their trucks they've got the
trump flags
and antifa because they own the streets
and because the cops have been told to
stand down
confrontation occurs so the patriot
prayer guards aren't shooting the
members of antifa who are trying to
literally block traffic instead they are
missing them so here's what the uh
here's what some of the video looked
like
over the weekend you can see they are
firing mace from the windows to try and
force the streets open
people getting out of the way uh they
were also firing paintballs at some of
the
at some of the antifa members hey is any
of this good
of course none of this is good where the
hell are the cops where the hell are the
feds and the answer is mayor ted wheeler
is a garbage mayor this stuff is
predictable
when you leave the legitimate government
monopoly on the use of force
at the back door then there will be
something that fills the gap and
typically it tends to be tribal violence
okay that is what you are seeing in the
streets okay then
a pro-trump supporter was murdered
literally just murdered on the street
okay so here is the video it's troubling
obviously
you can't see it particularly well but
that is your warning so you will see
a man in the background walk up to a
walk up to another man
and literally just shoot him point blank
and what you can what you seem to be
able to hear in the background
is we got a trumper here right we have a
trump supporter so that means time to
murder him apparently here's what that
sounded like
you shot a man to death right there on
the street this antifa member
and now we have uh we have some no
knowledge of who this guy is because he
is indeed an antifa member he is not a
white supremacist who committed this
murder
okay according to the new york post an
ex-military man who calls himself 100
antifa 100 antifa and ready for war
is being investigated over the deadly
shooting of a president trump supporter
in portland
according to a report his name is
michael forrest rhino
48 he's being investigated over the
death of aaron danielson
a supporter of the right-wing patriot
prayer group who was part of a caravan
of trump supporters who flooded the city
saturday police sources told the
oregonian
he was identified in part by a
distinctive tattoo on his neck of a
black power fist
hmm seems he had some politics as well
as a call from his estranged sister who
recognized him in video and photos of
the deadly attack
apparently he's estranged from most of
the family including his parents after
stealing from them
he regularly posts about black lives
matter and protests on his social media
he says i'm 100 antifa all the way i'm
willing to fight for my brothers and
sisters insisting he would not run
from the violence now here's the thing
he was cited at a july 5th protest on
allegations of possessing a loaded gun
in a public place
resisting arrest and interfering with
police he was then given a date to
appear in court later that month
but the allegations were dropped on july
30th with no complaints according to
court records
no reason was given the moma county
district attorney's office said it was
reviewing the case this is
literally a case of a person who
committed a criminal act but was on the
right side
of the leftist narrative being released
without any charges
because the city of portland decides not
to prosecute anymore
people who engage in crime at these
protests so long as they have the right
perspective
and then he went out and murdered
somebody okay the response
from members of the crowd when they
found out that this happened were
twofold one
misinformation immediately went around
that a trump supporter had shot a black
man because this is
this is what happens now and any story
is immediately filled in
by the internet with black man innocent
black man shot right this just happened
in minneapolis when a
black murder suspect literally killed
himself and committed suicide and
rioting happened anyway
so the false story led to rioters
targeting a gas station
because that makes perfect sense it's
the gas station's fault that gas station
is systemically racist obviously
so there are the rioters targeting the
gas station oh he's
always a good look gathering at the
uh at the petrol station preparing for
something or other
okay and then there's a blm activist who
literally told a group of people in
portland
i am not sorry this is direct quote i'm
not sorry an effing fascist died tonight
now is there any evidence this guy was a
fascist the victim in this case
nope i'm not angry you're not paying
attention
if you're not angry you're not with me
everybody needs to realize what's going
on
[Music]
[Applause]
well i mean there's no evidence the
person's a fascist but if you oppose the
revolution you're a fascist that's the
way communists speak
and then that is if you're if you're not
a bolshevik or a menshevik right that's
that's the way this works